hi my name is Marvin Ambrose's and I'm
here at Samuel leaves house and we this
is day one of our 12 month challenge now
this is to get a six pack in twelve
months but little bit so it's not just
about the six pack in 12 months this
challenge is about a total health and
well-being challenge it's about changing
his lifestyle everything in around is an
entire team and ensuring that not only
is he gonna have the sustainable and
good change of weight towards bloody
weights gonna go down he's gonna become
fitter healthier what we're gonna do is
have something that lasts for a lifetime
because this isn't something about a
quick fix this is something that's gonna
have for the rest of his life are you
guys ready I know I'm ready let's go
[Music]
it's funny how I had to go too long in
this because most people sending his
resolution for himself and then if there
really are poor they might get PJ but
men like you know you've done something
we're talking about accountability when
you told me about the video that you
made and how long ago you made it the
fact that you made the video yeah that
means you knew you already
yeah then to do the post I know that
must have too much group you guys yeah
it must have taken so much because then
watch what is out there you know this
different eyes in the situation
yeah well then I knew it just from
meeting you and then going through the
business house yeah because that's what
my friend said it to me all that P
cheese in the past but you know it's
like you want me to inspire you you also
sleep with your person because I want
someone who's good with my mental the
only other people then a person we just
had a synergy and now I've been where
you've been in terms of your weight and
how you felt about yourself and having
that understanding but understanding
that there's not just a change of it
tomorrow we could change your whether
you faster than we wanted but it's the
behavioral change forever that we need
and that's what
which are always a slide to the guys
converted market making it happen
yeah that offered me on the spot we're
doing this nu so I'm member will be
needed for reading today well first of
all time killer bikini French that's
pretty good
okay so this is what we're gonna be
getting rid of now what is that the Reds
the Cheesecake don't get me wrong I love
myself a good cheesecake yeah but this
is where we have to yell oh yeah yeah
okay actually I'm proud of you witnessed
it who he covered I was gonna have like
Kit Kats wagon wheels like crisps
walk-ins
what was like an out laughs what you
were going to go crazy but this actually
isn't terrible because you've got but he
loves these
there's no longer these but then again
these are quite high in sugar yeah and
you don't have a lot of we have the end
the right answer for it
we're doing a work I said to do a weapon
you can have one of these prior or even
often you'd be absolutely far way up to
do with those two or three of those a
day maxximum I might have probably two
but we're having two sessions in a day
I'd probably get use up to those and
yeah
Marvin reckons that or definitely no we
have been hit my goals like before in
said personal trainers but you need some
looks like kicking back and that's what
he wants
yeah not just always gonna be polite
okay oh yeah
well the fingers the accountability is
around in front of your face and I'm
here yeah it's got any in the morning
hey you want to take me now yes pretty
much like I'm here with it to do work
but yes I know what I need from you
you need to get changed yeah get ready
and then we're gonna get this started
all right I'm coming all right four
months tops now yes
are you ready already and you ready for
your time yes this is how we're gonna do
I do
they were Allegiance
[Music]
and that concludes our first day one of
our 12 months we won't even call it what
it is it this is a lifestyle 12 month
change leading to the six pack yes a
really intense section power my heaviest
I got to was just shy of 18 stone okay
and then I dropped down to 50 into the
pot and now I'm 16 and a half with the
15 and I was gonna come really quickly
yeah that's gonna be really fun you'll
get that like me I want to might for use
when I'm gonna be like the 14 is when I
would you be like all right yeah and I
know I know like when me there's gonna
point there's gonna be a point where we
drop to where someone's gonna say to you
warning you now oh that's enough now
he's skinny you're gonna get that you're
gonna get so much people saying that was
you yeah I'm about 14 3 now 6 - but the
lowest I ever went to I got to 13 and I
look ill no I looked sick but it's
because I went to 7 percent body fat and
I was ripped like I've the pictures of
it it looks like like what were you
doing but yeah but all it was was that I
literally lived and breathed whatever
went in my body was only for my physical
Lyme aesthetic so I lived like that for
about 4 months and that's how it works
but wasn't happy it stuffy if I stick to
your mouth faulty little stone that's
probably perfect health
well oh yeah I'm flying in what I'm
doing
a menacing spot so you got coupon which
is hot yeah so all I'm just thinking
about 14 Stan yeah for me that but I
feel like it's more than achievable but
for me I'm not just looking at your way
I'm looking to get you to a point where
your aesthetic doesn't matter what the
way is your aesthetics gonna be what it
is and you're gonna see that and be like
whatever that scale says check this out
like yeah I'm healthy yeah you're just
gonna be healthy and you're gonna feel
good you're gonna look good yeah I'm
just gonna be at a point where we're
gonna prolong your life as well so you
can do more of this help other people
man that was a hard session it was
really really hard enough to have
finished
Marvin stretched me it was the nicest
feeling I'm not taking over yet yeah
[Music]
he's a nice feeling and in terms of the
workouts he didn't actually feel any
pain any discomfort nothing at all I
tell them I'm already gonna get addicted
yeah you are you're gonna be coming to
like obviously classes I teach and
locally we're gonna be doing nothing at
least you can come to those classes and
I'll be fun if I think you've got a
class oh yeah like I'm I'm crazy I got
mad but it's all about you want to just
empower people to have fun with what
they're doing as well because if you
don't have if you don't enjoy the
process then there's no point in doing
it because at the moment now yeah you
say mark guess what I don't need you
anymore and then all of a sudden you
didn't enjoy the process you're not
gonna continue with what we were doing
yeah you remind me the way that you
teach is based on the tell I do at the
property space okay hard but then with a
smile with love mostly on the good thing
is though the level of focus you have
when you're working out like everybody's
got a look that they have when they work
out and you've got a look that you have
in your face that probably no one's seen
before it's just everyone's got one but
it's
you have to put yourself somewhere else
it's a different headspace yeah and then
once you get in there and you're like
yeah we're good we're ready yeah
[Music]